the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu so we have Carmen today
we're going to talk about how actually
do parallel is a much closer to hardware
and so first just a clarification this
talk is not really about any techniques
this is some very preliminary ideas that
I have some new ideas on parallel
programming the second thing is 56 years
ago I was going around the country
giving a talk why hardware design can't
be left to Hardware designers because I
think there was there is the way they
express their ideas is very very low
level from software point of view so I
worked really hard on injecting some
fairly sophisticated ideas from software
into hardware design but it often
happens when you deal with you know
powerful people you know you get
affected by it so I have sort of come
the full circle now I'm going to show
you how hardware design can influence
software design and that's really the
idea behind this talk so that's hence
borrowing some ideas from hardware
design just a Cell processor is a very
good example of a system-on-a-chip and
this is what everybody believes the
future will look like that you will have
fairly symmetric things in some sense
and that is needed by hardware because
hardware gets out of hand you know if if
you have wires running all over the
place so people would like these things
to be fairly you know regular in some
sense but that doesn't mean that you
know all these tiles have to be the same
so for example you may have very
application-specific blocks you know on
your chip so for example
in your cell phone you have many many
blocks which are specialized especially
all the radio communication because if
you did that stuff in software you may
not be able to meet the performance and
even if you can meet the performance
your battery will drain instantaneously
I mean it just takes too much power to
do that kind of computation you know in
software so for various reasons we need
application-specific processing units
and I'm sure cell processor has quite a
few of these then we need by the way
these application specific units are
often called a six and you can think of
them as a separate chip but in due
course of time they become blocks of a
bit bigger thing you may have
general-purpose processors already you
know systems have more than one such
things cell processor as how many like
eight it depends a year so the current
PlayStation savvy this supposedly seven
buggy be if I'd only sees so the way
flight is they will ease me I got out of
all the things we hear and high-end cell
phones have you know two general-purpose
processors and two arm I too sorry
general purpose forces into DSPs on it
so you will certainly have you know
multiple processors you will have memory
banks etc and you will have structured
on-chip interconnection networks so I
think this is a little bit yeah this is
not controversial you know that this is
what the trajectory will look like in
future that doesn't mean that you know
all the chips will look the same you may
have different mixes of things depending
upon the application and and one of the
interesting things is you know can you
put together one of these things fast
enough because it's very very expensive
to design and implement these things so
really the one issue that comes up all
the time is can be rapidly produce high
quality chips and surrounding systems
and software for such thing so this talk
as I said you know it's about ideas and
what I'm going to do is I first going to
tell you how I used to think about
parallel programming
and then I will you know and this way is
it's all about threads you know where
are my threads and I worked on this
problem for very very long time like you
know 20 years and this is not
necessarily wrong I mean you know I'm
sure in this course itself you have seen
quite a bit about this and I think
tomorrow's lecture is on silk so you
will see even more about threads and
lately I've been thinking about it
differently and really the main point I
would like to get across somehow to you
is now I think of a parallel programming
module as a resource you mean as a
resource I'll try to you know make it
more concrete this idea and and the
whole issue here is I think this this
viewpoint is valuable but it's not
proven yet you know so it may not be
right you know so just a warning I've
been working with this on students need
of the way in particular now those of
you who have heard of transactional
programming lots of things I will say
you say oh you mean a transaction yes I
mean oh so there are very very strong
connections with transactional stuff but
that's not the language I'm going to be
using here these slides are color coded
so when I'm talking about old way of
thinking it's yellow and when it's new
thinking that it's white so I think you
probably have already heard this at the
only reason for parallel programming
used to be performance this made
programming extremely difficult you have
to know a lot about the machine you know
your programming in codes or not
portable endless performance tuning all
this still goes on I mean very few of
these things have changed right Darla
libraries were not composable and this
is one of the main things I worry about
a lot and I think Alan was alluding to
it to you know somebody has code he just
wants to run the damn thing you know
even if factor of two speed up would be
what fantastic you know often it runs
slower if ever you ready
that little machines a very difficult to
deal with heap structures and memory
hierarchies and then there is always the
synchronization cost issue you know in
some sense parallel program doesn't make
sense if there is no synchronization
going on i mean that's like just
embarrassingly parallel computation you
know you just start off in things they
never talk to each other in even
moderately interesting parallel programs
there is always some communication you
know between various tasks and when that
happens and synchronization cost becomes
an issue and it is such a major issue
right now that you have to think about
it up front oh if I synchronize too much
then I know for a fact that my program
is going to run like a dog right so you
try to avoid synchronization and make
things coarser and so on really the the
whole issue used to be how to exploit
hundreds of threads from software
because new hardware will support many
many threads but at the same time it's
important to understand that in this
world there is always virtualization so
the more of threads in your machine is
never going to match exactly what you're
having your application right so any
programming model you have
virtualization is a very important
aspect of it that I have n threads and n
may be dynamic maybe varying with time
you know in my application but in
Hardware I have some fixed number of
threads right which is significantly
smaller in general then what you have in
your application so the thing I was most
interested in all those days was what I
call implicit parallelism you know and
from the questions I was hearing about
analysis you're doing of your programs
all those issues come up there you know
given some code can I figure out you
know what can be done in parallel and
just run it like that so extract
parallelism from programs written in
sequential languages then people like
some other champions in this and I have
also spent lots and lots of time on this
research problem so this is one of those
areas which certainly has not suffered
because of lack of research there's tons
and tons of research in this you know
you can go to IBM and you know there
will be 50 PhD is working on Fortran
compiler you know trying to extract
parallelism right so but the success is
limited in fact the the main takeaway
from this research is people have
learned now how they should write their
programs so that compiler has a chance
of extracting parallelism because now
people look at your code they say well
you don't know this is a bad code why
because compiler can't analyze it right
so sort of you become part of the
equation in this now the methodology I
was pushing for a long time was
functional languages programs in
functional languages which may not
obscure parallelism in the first place
I'm not going to talk about functional
languages and it's the material you know
whether this is a good idea or a bad
idea the fact of the matter isn't in
real life people's reaction is
functional languages are you kidding me
right you know it's sort of so it
doesn't get off ground right this is one
of those things I can come and preach to
you it's good for your soul you know
where they say leave me alone you know I
don't do movies and you know the
subtitles right yes sorry to temporarily
derail you sorry sorry to temporarily
derail you huh like um so what kind of
what what kind of parallel ISM is easier
to is easier to extract from a
functional language so I can clearly see
some task parallelism is it also can you
also extract data parallelism or
pipeline parallelism might clean up i
think it turns out that's actually not
the right question to ask in the
functional language sense because
function language doesn't obscure the
parallelism that was there in the first
place so you already have a partial
order on operations as opposed to a
sequential order you see when you write
in fortran
even a simple thing like you know f of G
of X H of Y right it may be obvious to a
functional programmer that these things
can be done in parallel perhaps the
execution of these can overlap with the
evaluation of F but that's not the
semantics of Fortran or any other
sequential language the semantics is
you're supposed to execute the program
left to right top to bottom right so you
will go and execute G first and you will
go inside G and execute it and then you
will go and execute h and then you will
go and execute f in that why is that
important because there are side effects
you know so it's conceivable that you
know you do something in this which
affects this and so on so you are given
a sequential order and then compile it
as deep analysis the kind you are doing
right now in terms of dependence and
anti-dependence and so on right which
says it's okay to do GNH in parallel
well if it was a functional program then
you know by the semantics of the
language G and H can be done in parallel
that doesn't mean it's a good idea to do
it in parallel so when we get to the
second point of mapping this computation
on to a given substrate of two
processors or ten processors then
problems become similar but the problem
of detecting parallelism is very
different you know because you don't
talk of detecting parallelism in
functional languages it's already there
you know you don't obscure it does that
make sense
and it goes without saying that you know
if your algorithm has no parallelism
then function languages or any other
language there's no magic right i mean
you can't suck blood out of stone so you
have to know your algorithm you have to
know whether you know what operations
can be done in parallel right so
language only is an aid in some sense
that if it was parallel I could express
it more easily as a parallel program
right and if it's a bad language you
know you obscure it and then you try to
undo the damage now as I said you know
there has been a lot of success in this
in terms of dense matrix kind of stuff
but more irregular the computation
harder it gets to do these things
statically so you know when you can't do
it then people of course designed
explicitly parallel programming models
and and some of the most successful ones
in this our data parallel and you hear
about multi-threading tomorrow itself
and then there are very low level models
where you are doing actual message
passing you know between various modules
that are sitting over there and I can
expose your threads and synchronizations
at a very low level folk and join etc so
of course higher level models are
preferable because you are likely to
make fewer errors in them the question
is can we compile them and in some cases
what turns out is like like this is a
good model but it is not general enough
you know so if you have a data parallel
algorithm fine I mean you know you
should use these things but not all
applications fit the data parallel model
multi-threading in some sense is more
general this is what I mean by a
multi-threaded model that you know you
may have a main which spawns off things
so not only these things can be done in
parallel but execution of these can
overlap with the execution of F so
parents and children may be executing
simultaneously so if you look at this as
an activation
you know this invokes a loop you know
which has many many iterations in it
when we talk of sequential computing you
are always sitting on one branch of this
right so that's the stack this tag this
tag you know stack frames right when you
talk of parallel computing then part of
this activation tree is concurrently
active right so all problems get harder
I with storage management gets harder
and what gets specially harder is that
there is this global heap right you
always have heap and interesting
programs global data structures now the
problem is if this and this are active
at the same time or this and this are
active at the same time and they are
both reading and writing into the data
structure then naturally there is a race
condition in this even if only one guy's
writing and five people are reading it
it's a question of the guys should not
read it too soon so the moment you do
any kind of parallel programming
synchronization issues arise immediately
you know you always have to worry about
how do I indicate that it's okay to read
this well you can follow some control
ideas you say this guy was writing he
has finished execution so it must be
okay to write or you can go to very
fine-grained synchronization you can
have some bit here which says oh this
data has been you know updated now it's
okay to you know unlock it and read it
and so on so all these ideas have been
explored and they are still being
explored right in this context the main
takeaway is there is instead of a stack
you will have a tree which is active at
the same time you know many many things
are going on and the second thing is
that there is a competition there is a
race in reading the heap data structures
and therefore you have to worry about
that you don't read it too soon no you
don't write it too soon because if you
write it too soon you make clobber
before somebody else gets a chance to
read it right so these issues are quite
serious now it's really possible i mean
i claim you know i have languages which
can express computation very efficiently
this way efficiently is not the right
word
easily you can express computation in
this way but at the end of the day the
goal is to take that stuff and run it
somewhere on some parallel machine
whether its cell processor in the old
days it would have been in a parallel
machines are various herbs and that has
proven to be quite difficult efficient
mapping of these things because it turns
out that you say oh you didn't tell me
before you have only two processors then
I would have you know express the
computation differently right or you
didn't tell me that you have 1000
processors you know so there is this
kind of yes there is virtualization but
it's not virtual enough you know
qualitatively matters a lot you know
what is the target and that affects how
you would have expressed the computation
so I used to go around saying this all
the time that you know parallel
programming is so important that really
sequential programming will be taught as
a special case of parallel programming
because it will be all parallel right
and you know if you have only one
processor then you can teach you some
special tricks how to run it efficiently
on one processor so this as you can see
is largely an unrealized dream so not
one to be dismissed absolutely so the
question is has a situation change in
the situation has certainly changed so
multicores have arrived this is a big
deal I mean from Microsoft now wants to
battle and there can be no bigger
indication than this you know you know
and there is explosion of cell phones
and if you don't understand what that
means is economically you know there are
a hundred million pc that will be sold
this year and 950 million cell phones
that will be sold this year this is the
same kind of transition that is taking
place that happened in early 80s you
know when we went from mainframes and
mini computers to micros right so what
happens there determines what happens
everywhere else so it's quite possible
that what happens on these small
Isis you know handheld devices will
determine the architecture of everything
else just because you know of the
numbers you know people are willing to
invest a lot more money into this
explosion of game boxes I'm sorry
explosion laughs is awesome yeah but
that still that number is 100 million
right well cell phone is 950 million so
at least in two thousand right right
absolutely so look if I'm talking to you
as a teacher I mean you know my message
to my colleagues in the department is
it's no longer good enough to say well
we teach you parallelism when you are a
sophomore right I mean it is the thing
that people want to deal with you know
this is what do you mean you're telling
me how to program one processor you know
I have 10 of them in my pocket right so
so I think we have to deal with this you
know how do we introduce parallelism
what what method we should have for
teaching parallel programming you know
so that that is the default programming
model in your head so it's all about
paddle is now no longer an advanced
topic it has to be the first topic just
another word of caution in this so let's
look at cell phones right so mine you
know has some bugs in it so sometimes it
misses a call and I am surfing the web
right it doesn't ring okay so this is
the deep question now so whose fault is
it right but for example to what extent
the phone call software should be aware
of web surfing software or vice versa so
now you have to understand how these
things are done of course how the phone
calls are made that software has been
evolving right you can look at it over
the last 15 years you know and it's it's
you can you'll be able to trace a
continuum you know how phone calls are
made in that and that's not trivial
amount of saw software on your cell
phone well when it comes to web surfing
software I can guarantee you it was
from scratch right people went to your
PC they say what do you do on your web
you know they take all that software say
let's sport it on the cell phone now the
guy who wrote the web software never
thought you'll be talking on telephone
you know while you're surfing the web or
at least not on the same device right
and vice versa the guy who wrote the
phones off never thought you know that
you will be surfing the web you know
while you're talking on the phone I mean
in even in 1995 or you know 1998 if
somebody had said you will be surfing
the web at the same time it would have
sounded pretty bizarre right it just
won't have made so is it nearly a
scheduling issue so this is the answer
you are you know they didn't process
interrupt properly I'm sorry this is not
just a scheduling issue I don't even
know the semantics of this so for
example if you're surfing the web and
the phone rings do you really want to
stop surfing the web and pick up the
phone I mean what's so special about
phone I mean there is nothing being
indicated from the language point of
view right it may be application
requirement that you want to stop it or
not stop it and so on is it a
performance issue that oh it's because
you have only two processors in this if
you had for this problem will go away or
if you could just run it faster it'll go
away I don't think any of these answers
are right right i mean the bottom line
in this is sequential modules are often
used in concurrent environments with
unforeseen consequences so your mindset
has to be that i'm going to put together
a parallel program with lots of existing
things right because you can't keep
giving the answer oh let's just rewrite
it again from scratch you know because
amount of software is so enormous in
this what we should worry about now is
how we should design these modules how
we should write pieces of software or
design hardware so that we can put
together an ensemble of them you know a
collection of such modules so that they
do something useful right and it's all
about parallelism
do all this in a parallel setting ok so
new goals as opposed to the old balls so
I don't want to think in terms of
decomposition I don't want to think in
terms of here is my clever algorithm
right how do I decompose it so that this
runs here and this runs here and so on
instead I want to think in terms of
synthesis that you have already given me
lots of modules you know which are very
useful which perhaps are written by
domain experts they know something about
that stuff and can I put together a
bigger application very quickly from it
and you know another favorite example of
mine in this regard is you know fftw and
linear algebra packages both have been
optimized to the hilt right and if
somebody gives you an application which
calls enough FFT and uses enough linear
algebra I guarantee you that program
will not be easy to write in spite of
the existence of both these packages
right which are extremely well optimized
so there is something we are not paying
attention to is how do we bring parallel
modules together in such a way so that
the functionality the performance etc
are predictable in some sense I think we
really partners make sure i understand
but then take them the fft WLAN router
is not enough and so they were looking
no no i think it's it's very well done
fftw linear algebra is very well done
but we still haven't provided any good
way of thinking in terms of two parallel
things you know what happens when they
interact ok right so if my program is
calling fftw often and then it's called
a linear algebra but often running so
actually that that you are here when i
mention that but I was actually bringing
up the point was in yahoo and effort of
you working together just working
exactly
right right right exactly absolutely so
I'm saying in that sense you see this is
a different way of thinking because the
old way of thinking was well give me the
application now let's decompose it the
point is I don't have experts you know
who can write fftw as well as Mateo
wrote it you know how whose have a
linear algebra packages are being
written I want to use those things i
want to synthesize large parallel
programs quickly yes sorry how does
apple iphone i think it will be i think
from our point of view that's the same
thing is just that the user interface is
guaranteed to be far superior because in
my phone when i see the icons imma take
it i still can't understand half of them
right so I like apples idea you know
phone pictures they that were my TV that
it is going to not let anybody program
it's good a very restrictive developer
program internally so they can basically
say sort of i'm going to take this
process and his present put it together
they will try to do everything in the
lack of my one unified way so two
subjects and it might work but but then
then you suddenly realize apple cart hi
a program was to keep up with all the
needs in there so so maybe start to have
other people funny things if things
break sorry you know if usually their
software is oh god indeed they'll be
paddled stop going on there guaranteed
because all the communications stuff has
to go on in parallel with the
computation stuff so I mean phones have
to do lots of things in parallel just if
for no other reason just because of
power you know it takes less power when
you do things in parallel when you as
opposed to when you do it sequentially
because then you have to run much faster
you know in that okay so a method of
designing and connecting modules as that
functionality and performance are
predictable and must facilitate not
natural description of concurrent
a method of refining individual modules
into hardware or software for systems on
a chip so refinement is a word it's a
highly technical world you would what
that means is that you have written a
program and you may want to rewrite it
but nobody can tell from outside that
you rewrote it all right so you refine
it and you can refine it into hardware I
mean you may implement it in hardware in
this as opposed to transformation
transformation is automatic you know
we'll be doing something it's guaranteed
it's correct refinement you may have to
work a little bit more to show that it's
correct in some sense it's a correct
refinement of whatever you were doing so
basically you know just to get the
application going which as Alan is
pointing out is the major task and this
is true regardless of what people say
when you get to complex system if people
start talking about performance you're
ninety percent there that means the damn
thing works right so even though people
may say our performance will be lousy
most of the energy is just consumed in
getting it to work right so never forget
that so a refinement idea becomes very
important because you want to take as
many things as possible which are
available right make it work and then
individually refine modular refinement
of things that they can sell after to
perform just like you say no just a
factor to on you know 100 processor
whatever they can sell that if it works
is the right answer if the ease it's the
you know the ease and confidence that
it's really doing what you expected of
you it's really perform in seconds ease
of use versus that you've got a package
in a cadenza a method of mapping such
designs on to multi cause right so why
multi-core problems becomes hard and
this is where hardware and software
starts diverging a little bit so what
happens in hardware design everything is
in parallel right
I mean it's sitting right there you know
this blog does this this blog does that
right so there is no confusion in your
mind you know what's going on in
parallel if you have to multiplex
something in hardware you know that Oh
first we will do this and we'll do that
that's also expressed explicitly in the
design software is not like that you
know software you know I have n threads
but I have only ten in my hardware so
there is another layer of you know
software or operating system or whatever
you want to call it runtime system whose
sole job is to virtualize or to do time
multiplexing of underlying resources and
that makes the problem harder you know
that makes the problem harder whether
you're doing it in a way that preserves
and performance goes whether you're
doing it so that you won't cause
deadlock so there are many many issues
that come up in this and basically when
I said this is an idea is kind of a talk
I do know how to do this right and I
still haven't worked enough on this
problem of how to you know take this
kind of methodology where i can write
these parallel modules compose them how
to map it onto multi-course ok so now
let me tell you something a technical
about this stuff so this Hardware
inspired methodology for synthesizing
parallel programs so now I'm going to
use some fancy word so this is a
rule-based specifications or what I call
guarded atomic actions I will explain in
a second what that means and it will let
you think about that no system is in a
very different way so you it's like
saying look if this register is 2 and
this register is 3 you can add them and
put them here five right and you can do
this anytime you want right so this is
like a rule invariant you know you're
saying I don't care what's happening in
the machine this is always safe to do
now what I'm going to ask you to do is
take a huge intellectual jump from this
that if you give me enough such rules
you would have completely described the
hardware what it does right now why am I
thinking like this because
these invariants are stated properly
it's always possible to understand the
behavior of the system as if one thing
at a time is happening when two plus
three is becoming five you if you want
you can have this mental picture the
rest of the world is frozen nothing is
changing their only that change is
taking place and you can think in terms
of these small small changes and all
legal behaviors will be explainable as
some sequence of these changes it's
possible to describe all kinds of
hardware you know using things like that
composition of modules with guarded
interfaces so this is the language
called blue speck and it has a very
strong echoes of a language that was
designed in 80s by two guys Chandi and
Mishra the language called unity right
but they never use it for hardware
design I mean their goals were different
and they didn't really have a concept of
a module in that language so let me show
you three examples here greatest common
divisor just to get off ground and then
i will show you two very different
problems airline reservation query
problem and the video codecs H dot 264
we won't have time to get into ordered
list but if somebody wants to discuss
that I will be happy to show you okay so
now let's look at how do I think of my
design of my program in blue speck I
always think in terms a bunch of modules
right and what's the module a module is
going to have some state elements in it
if you are thinking software just think
each module guards some variables which
nobody else can touch right you are the
only one you know so you have variable X
Y Z he has some ABCD etcetera right so
each module has some so that's what i'm
showing in red if you are thinking
hardware think of these things as
stateful elements like you know
registers or flip-flops or memories
right but the main point is if it is
here then it's not here I mean these are
you know you on something
what'd you learn something this model
own something one second thing is every
module has internal rules for
manipulating this state and the rules
are always going to be of the form that
if some condition is true on this you
are allowed to make the following
changes to that right so that's what the
rule looks like some condition if it
holds that by action I mean change the
state change the state of those
variables and it's all or nothing so if
you have two variables and if you want
to change both of them in a rule then
execution of a rule means either both of
them will change or neither will change
there is nothing in between you can see
right that's disallowed by this model
all right now rules are of course I mean
the reason I have modules as they are
not totally disjoined you can actually
access the state both read it and write
it but you can't just orbiting do
something you have to go through some
interface methods the moment you talk to
some other modules so this is the
standard information hiding principle
you know abstract data types whatever
you want to call it you know so there is
an interface through which you will
enter and if you're just reading the
values I think we call them read methods
or value methods and if you're going to
affect the state of on other modules we
will call those action methods right
because you're actually going to change
the state in some module so now very
straight execution model here very very
different from sequential execution
model so repeatedly you do the following
you pick a rule to execute any I don't
care right and select a rule to execute
compute this state you know what update
should be made make the state update and
then go and do it again you know so
repeatedly you do this so this is a
highly non deterministic thing right
selector or I mean you know they may be
gazillion rules in your system right so
system will primitives are provided to
control the selection if you want but
it's a detail that we won't get into
so does everybody get the model right
here that you have lot of state elements
and you have lot of rules many rules may
be applicable pick one of them to
execute right executed that will change
the state ask the same question again
which rules are enabled now pick any
rule amongst them and keep doing it now
semantics say one rule at a time in any
implementation we're going to do many
many rules in parallel right but you
don't have to worry about that that will
be done all automatically right that we
can do many rules in parallel okay so
now let's look at G C D so this is an
ordinary GCD program you can write it in
any language you want if y0 the next
otherwise if this is greater than gcd of
YX otherwise you subtract ok so no
problem and I'm sure you know how it
executes so if I was to take GCD or 615
if you will see there is a recursive
call that will go on because 6 is less
than 15 so it will be this you get this
and you get this etc ultimately you get
3 as an answer everybody's with me you
know you all know GCD you can all write
it in your favorite language now the
question is what does it mean to execute
this program in a conference setting we
were not thinking parallel or sequential
write this is GCD you know now somebody
has someone you know is teaching this
class a run it in parallel you say what
do you mean runs in parallel oh you mean
that maybe I should try to do several
GCD calls you know recursive calls in
parallel that also doesn't make too much
sense in this right perhaps this is what
someone meant you know that if he has
some program where there are two calls
to GCD right he would like you to do
those those two in parallel right I mean
what does it mean to do GCD in parallel
now let me contrast this with how you
would think about this problem is a
hardware person so your job is to build
a gcd machine you're going to make
millions of dollars you know this GCD is
very popular right so you build this GCD
machine you know it has two inputs it
has an output and this will be my module
I'm going to sell this intellectual
property right to everyone okay so now
let me talk of parallel invocations of
this you see in Hardware there can be no
confusion either you have two GCD boxes
or you have one gcd box right i mean you
can have as many boxes as you want right
but there is no confusion about that you
know how many g cds you have so in some
sense if you have many of them you know
you're talking of independent calls
right who knows what's about recursive
calls I that's internal story you know
that's a different level of questions so
this question will automatically get us
in hardware you will ask the question
does the answer come out immediately
right does it come out in predictable
time why is this question important
because if it's going to take some time
then while it's computing the question
I'm going to ask is can I give another
set of inputs are you with me right I
mean that's a legitimate question to ask
you know if it's going to take half an
hour to compute the GCD can I give it
another input you know while it's
thinking can the machine be shared by
two different users right can it be
pipelined so you agree that all these
questions are meaningful and hardware
setting and I claim all these questions
are also meaningful and software setting
we just don't think like that this is
exactly the problem we are having right
now you know when we say that we have
optimized something and we call it again
right we think of it as starting a fresh
maybe not maybe not you know maybe we
should think of it in terms of resources
you know and and the point I want to
make is I want to think of GCD module as
a resource even in software I want to
think of it as a resource so that there
is no ambiguity in your mind whether you
have one GCD or you have to G Series
right if you're going to multiplex it
will write it differently if you're
going to have two independent 10 which
can go on in parallel we write it
differently okay so that's the idea I
want to borrow you know from the
hardware side in this so how would you
do it is would you decide how many GCPs
to instantiate with that d in this model
left up to the programmer well you see
that's the big difference in hardware
and software that in hardware you have
no design until you have taken that
decision right but in software you'd
like you're so I mean hardware designs
once it's built it's built software
designs you want the same module of
software to seamlessly run on different
kinds of hardware that doesn't mean that
I can't become pilot or gone you know
resynthesizer to Sun right but if you it
may be same source description and
software right if your source
description specifies to GTD modules
right and you have eight cores right
you're not necessarily going to take
very good advantage of so how do you do
oh no no the way you i would like to
think about that is that you will it
will be highly parametrized code and you
will plug in some information like that
and resynthesizer parallel process the
software software or some sort of macro
meta software has to has to determine
the extent to which the problem should
be distributed well you can think like
that but really this integration will be
much tighter than you think so for
example let me just give you some more
insight from the hardware side so in the
hardware side its standard practice that
I will have some RTL code I'll have some
code right and I plug in the library
what kind of gates have I bought haven't
got to input gates for input gates
whatever you know there may be a huge
library right the same code can be
compiled using different libraries so
you choose something or synthesis time
another thing that will happen in
hardware is what is called generic
statement so you may have a loop which
instance shades a register file with n
registers right which way conceptually
make sense it may make sense in
simulation but when it comes to
synthesizing it you have to specify n
right so I'm going towards that kind of
methodology that you will have highly
parameterize code but many parameters
you would have to specify before you
will say now my program is ready to run
on this panel machine and this is
totally unexplored yet I mean this just
as I said this is in my ideas level that
it so this adds problem that it's not in
traditional hardware since this is
mainly picking all the ends ideally you
wouldn't want to have to have the
programmer to come up with creative
algorithms because they're gonna have
lots and lots absolutely you know that
we may have lots of default even have
other level of smart programs you know
which look at this and they instantly go
and set many parameters you know so
there will be a practical side many
issues like that but main point I'm
trying to make is that I really want to
synthesize I want to instantiate a
program synthesize a program for a given
configuration right of hardware let's
look at the GCD in blue speck so you
know if I'm going to find the GCD of two
numbers I need two registers x and y so
that's what this is make me a register
you know think if you want make me two
variables you know make me variable x
and y initial values are 0 so this is
what is called the state of the module
right it knows about x and y nobody else
knows about x and y right what is the
dynamics of it how do i compute this so
internal behavior is being described and
this is exactly what you saw earlier
it's saying that there is a swap rule if
x is greater than y and y is not equal
to 0 then you swap x and y so this is a
parallel composition X gets y of i get x
in this in this system all the reads
take place instantaneously and then
you do all the rights at the end of it
right so don't read this sequential you
know you read x and y in parallel and
then you go and update x and y does this
rule make sense I mean if you know
anything about GCD if X is greater than
the wire then we're going to swap it and
subtraction is if X is less than or
equal to Y then why gets y minus X so
this is very interesting now you have
two registers x and y and i have given
you two rules and i am saying you can
apply these rules anytime you want just
repeatedly keep doing these rules right
now what does the outside world know
about this what do you want to advertise
about GCD to the outside world you don't
want to give away your secret this is
your intellectual property of how you
are computing the GCD right you just
want them to use GCD so the outside
world can say Oh find me start it right
with a and B X gets a why gets be it's
going to give you two parameters but you
know we may be busy computing right so
we have a guard here which says if Y is
0 this is all internal outside world
doesn't see this right if Y is 0 then
you know only then you can start it
otherwise you can't start it otherwise
it means it's busy computing okay
similarly when is the result available
when the y is 0 then you have the result
and you will return X that's right so so
that would be get more sophisticated if
we and that's exactly the kind of
decision I do want the designers to take
you know because you may want to put a
fifo right you may just keep spitting
out reserves you you can make it as
sophisticated as you want tag it if you
want right no predetermined thing you
know this is just so first question I
asked you what happened to those
recursive calls
right you know if you go back to the
previous slide you know there was
recursively called GCD which you are all
comfortable with there is no GCD call
here right so there is a notion of a
cycle event or something right look at
it now updated look at it again you know
so there is like an infinite loop here
which is always going always going right
which is exactly how hardware works
right you're always you know if you it
doesn't have to be synchronous but if
you want to have a simple model in your
hair just think there's a clock you know
look at all this state take one rule to
execute update it then it's the next
clock cycle right keep doing this
repeatedly its details here but I can
take such a description and actually
produce that machine for you right which
does the GCD what I'm much more
interested in is this is how to think
about my GC leader so I've hidden
everything inside it right and it has
two methods start and result and there
is a very strong notion of when a method
is ready because it may be busy
computing it doesn't want to listen to
you right so there is this notion of
something being ready and if it's an
action method then you are only allowed
to enable it when it's ready so this is
a high level protocol that compiler will
enforce it will never ever said this you
know it will never execute this unless
it is ready to be executed and of course
when you're going to enable it then you
have to give me two arguments that go
with it and what does this really mean
result is valid right so if you are into
types etc this could easily be maybe
type or something you know you know tag
union type that valid bit it's being
coded here
so really to the world here if you know
just advertising this interface that you
know there is a gcd interface and it has
two methods and action method which is
called start and a result method which
is just a value kind of a thing and in
order to do this you have to give me an
Indian in to be in this and end of
interface now this is borrowing a lot
from modern programming languages so for
example I can easily make it polymorphic
it doesn't have to be ends here you know
what is the meaning of int i can
actually you know you know you can
specify the type in this right so it
will be type T you know is of type T B's
of type T etc what are the examples of
type T here you know it could be a
32-bit integer it could be 16 bit
integer it could be 17 bit integer
whatever you want and whatever makes
sense so this is the kind of thing that
you always take care of when you
synthesize things you know it won't
synthesize until you specify the type
but the description remains the same
right and you will instantiate it for a
given type this i'm showing you for one
reason if you were coming from the
hardware side really this these ideas
and types and installations as a travel
you get very sophisticated I mean this
is getting as advanced as you can have
in software the other very interesting
thing is and this is the abstract data
type kind of thinking you can go and
completely change the implementation of
this right if you have a cleverer
algorithm for doing GCD fine go ahead
and do it you know it doesn't affect the
users of this right so this is a very
important property for composition right
all I insist on is that every method has
this ready thing coming on so that I
don't make mistakes and wiring it right
I will invoke this method only when it's
ready so in some sense if you forget
about the ready thing I'm just borrowing
ideas from object oriented languages you
know you have a class you have methods
on it and all I'm saying is oh you know
you should manipulate this state
in a very systematic manner you know
using these methods but then I'm
injecting some hardware idea here which
doesn't exist it in software today that
is Oh a method may not be ready right
and even that can be captured very
abstractly and done properly in this yep
we can ship it in modules a synchronous
by nature like so if you basically a
given a basis I hardware you may watch a
better a better efficiency by having
sort of synchronous comfortable by
taking the output after certain number
of sight pretty from the number of
cycles right possible I think yes
that'll be a low level detail that if it
is synchronous that you will actually
try to manipulate it like that but okay
right okay so let me just quickly say
what the languages so you have modules
and you have state variables and you
have rules and you have action methods
and read methods what I wanted to show
you is what is the language of actions
right so you know when I write an action
here or an action here what is it so
simplest action is assignment to a
variable right assignment to a register
this is a conditional action so if
predicate is true then do this action
otherwise no action no change in state
right this is a parallel composition do
a 1 and a 2 in parallel right sequential
composition the effects of this are
visible to this etc this is a call to a
method of another module and then there
is a God and you have a an expression
language which is there's nothing
special here you know so this is just
simply you can have you can read a
variable you can have constants these
are just names and you can have you know
there's nothing special going on here
let me explain you guards so people find
guards versus ifs confusing and this is
one way to understand it so guards
affect the surrounding so if I wrote
here a 1 when p1 in parallel with a 2
think of God as something to do with
resources I really don't want you to do
a one unless p1 is true right p 1 may
reflect that the module was busy
whatever you know some predicate here
but I want the effect of this whole
thing to be atomic right so if any part
of it can't be done then the whole thing
can be done and therefore the effect of
guard is as if you wrote a one and panel
will too when p1 in other words guard on
anything becomes guard on everything in
that parallel composition do you
understand what I just said right that
it it this is very important for
composition of guards you know that I
because I want a Thomas city of the
whole thing to be preserved so if
anything can't be done that means the
whole thing can't be done on the other
hand conditional action is just
conditional action so if I have if p1
then a 1 in parallel with a 2 well
that's like saying if p1 was true then I
want to do a 1 and a 2 in parallel
otherwise I just want to do a two so
there is a very big difference between
conditional actions and guards guards
are something about resources I needed
for proper composition of atomic actions
yep I mean time equivalent though
because in I mean maybe a loan of a
question but in the first case so the
first on the status and the left how to
do start going into and then roll it
back or something that is a second case
you can't oh I think there may be many
tricks you can play an implementation
you can be optimal state you controlled
by naughty no no no they'll be
semantically this is defining the
semantics I mean this is the algebra
this this has to be true because by I'm
saying this is the this is what a guard
is right so that symantec equal
the equivalent in terms of what the
implementation might do when it sees the
two things well I mean that's probably
not the right way to say every need a
semantics are being defined you have
choice in implementations right I mean
I'm not telling you how to implement
this yeah let me go on with this so here
is a problem that was forced to me by
age I they've Mishra and this is quazy
realistic problem okay ask for quotes
from two airlines if one codes below 300
by immediately it was 300 sort of is the
cheapest ticket you get these days right
by the lower code if over 300 but at
some stage your patience runs out yeah I
can't wait anymore right so after one
minute by from who server has quoted
otherwise flag error is this a realistic
scenario now you can express it using
threads and you can write a scheduler
you know to do this etc those things are
not as succinct as you would like I mean
you'll be surprised in this simpler
problem how complicated and how many
questions will arise if you express this
as a threaded computation now let me
show you what you have what you would do
in blue speck okay so we are going to
make a module which does what may get
coats right this module is job is to get
quotes so what kind of state elements do
you expect it to have well airline a
maybe quoting some value airline be
maybe quoting some value whether we are
done or not there's a timer right which
we are going to be bumping etc and there
will be rules you know get a quote from
a you know which will be when not done
do something execute when a response
right get be timeout etcetera etcetera
there are many rules of this sort let me
just show you one method
okay so method is this is how you
started right do you have this mod
you'll get quotes and you're saying get
book me a ticket and this is your
requests are now obviously this can only
be done when the module is not busy
right if module is busy then you can't
do it so what will you do when you get
such a request tell me this makes sense
so what is the same try to get a request
from a in parallel try to get a request
from be right now you are busy right i
mean the module is busy so done equals
false here and I'm initializing this i'm
just saying that a code right now is
infinity and b code is infinity and
timer is 0 fair right and when will i
get ticket well when done then you will
return the ticket from this now let's
look at example of a rule so you may
have a rule like this right pick
cheapest you see the interesting thing
in this is you'll be able to read this
independently of what else is going on
in this system and let's see what does
this rule say is it succinct rule says
when you are not done right and if the
code from a is not infinite that means a
has coated right and b has also coated
right then what should happen if a is
less than B then buy the ticket from a
otherwise you will buy the ticket from B
and you're done
I am NOT going to write all these rules
but I think you should be able to really
i'm certain you can write these rules
this is what is happening here is just
separation of concerns right it's all
concurrent stuff right yes
thumb loop well like her lack of better
word the pipe in
so you see it again so at the gangers &
ampersand right how does that interact
with okay can you pull efficient for
another pair so ampersand after not done
yep that is like what what sort of
ordering is that it's just I mean
Associated commutative kind of thing you
know it's all happening in parallel
world ones huh this thing right I mean
think of it like these are variables
right and you're checking their values
right now so it's just a combinational
kind of a query that you have here I
guess you're checking there's no
activity that's right okay can be free
system it doesn't matter what or you
check so I guess what I'm trying yes and
the whole whack the top is executed in
parallel absolutely why not also things
that are correct are playing some should
you feel free server if I click the
conditions then you go to the read the
world you also and raising go to the
active so it's asking patients right so
now I just want to show you this because
this is completely different from the
airline reservations right you know H
dot 264 this is a codex that is being
used everywhere and will be used even
more oh and this is a typical data flow
diagram you will find you know for this
kind of thing you don't have to
understand anything but about this
except that you know these things
conceptually you just have five fours
for communicating between them right and
all such things the goal is that it has
to be able to sustain a certain amount
of rate at which need us to be processed
and it's usually forgiving in terms of
latency so if you know latency increases
a little bit here and there it's usually
okay right when things go in and come
out at data flow like network and
another reason why this example is
fascinating is because it's done
regularly both in hardware and software
and any mixture of the two so for
example when it runs on your PC you know
it's being done one hundred percent in
software and when it's being you know
there are I think on iPod that a
special-purpose hardware for doing it
and therefore the battery can last much
longer right and on cell phones it's
kind of in between in this and it's a
question of what frame rate you want to
process if you are processing very high
frame rate then it will have to be done
in hardware so when we got into this
thing you know we said okay let's try to
we wanted to build hardware for doing
this and reference codes are available
its 80,000 lines and it sort of gives
you a heart attack you know you read
this and he said whoa and it doesn't
meet the performance you know I mean
that reference code if it ran on your
laptop you won't be able to watch a
movie you know with this and then there
is the Linux version of it which gives
you in a bigger heart attack because
it's two hundred thousand lines and many
different codex's are mixed in this
the biggest problem here is none of
these codes reflect that picture I
showed you on the previous diagram
because the way people approach it in
software is they take some input from
here and they push it as far as they can
right and that's it then they will take
the next input and push it so different
boxes keep modifying it you know as they
see fit and as a reader you can tell
that oh this is the this part and this
is this part I mean there are no fifo
cues why because pfeiffer cues are
expensive in software you know it will
involve copying you know you will write
it here then you will read it again
which is a bad idea in software so in
some sense the software way of thinking
already entered you know in this in this
style of coding there is no model of
concurrency you know so it's not clear
to me when you give me that code what
all I can do in parallel in order to
preserve the semantics of this I mean
the problem is much much harder here
really so you will just do some high
level analysis of the code but you have
lost lot of information that was all
present in the source could have been
present in the source and my claim is it
can be done differently so if you this
has been done by a chunky and this i'm
showing you a month whole slide but he
has done a lot more work since then and
the total code in blue speck is nine
thousand lines for this contrasting it
with 80,000 versus 200,000 kind of stuff
and this is telling you the amount of
code in various you know blocks in this
and you know since it's done in blue
speck you can take it and you can go and
implement it all in hardware you know so
you can synthesize it it it actually
does now 45 frames per second actually
90 frames even per second today you know
so this is a month old this is the main
point once you have done this now you
can refine it you know you you have a
different preference
you say oh I want to do this differently
so you can go and rewrite any module
again right it will be very very easy to
do this is the system it is very
difficult to do this in the reference
code so that's one point to be made the
second thing is you don't have to do
everything in Hardware if you wanted you
could have implemented any part of it in
software so you can take the same kind
of a description and generate software
from it as well so each module can be
refined separately behaviors of modules
are composable you know you can take
these things and you it's predictable
what will happen when you compose these
things in terms of a performance and in
terms of resources also is very clear
what's happening in hardware the
resources will be area and time and so
on in this so take away parallel
programming should be based on
well-defined modules and parallel
composition of such modules modules must
embody a notion of resources and
consequently sharing in time multiplexed
we use this is a controversial point and
guarded Tomic actions and modules
regarded interfaces provide a solid
foundation thank you have questions you
can ask yep